Brennan's chilly it's Wednesday andis
little joy so cool in here do yours
little oh yeah will you show up in
t-shirts I told you it's still sweater
eleventy eight degrees that's still
smells me 22 yeah it's true
summers here you you like everywhere
short sleeves huh did the Kermit arms
yeah got the cook-off gods to the
Kermit's a little bit dude rock the
Kermit's and my rocks of pumpkin Jax
think you with your arms Rock the
pumpkin jack alright well no I I work
short sleeve shirt just can't really say
we have I just been it's been a little
chilly okay I should wear my t-shirts
has been a tad blow my arms out bro long
as I don't eat so when you lift weights
you don't need to stay skinny you know
no matter what you do what'd he say well
you too old wait I mean I'm saying it's
like you're you could eat all the food
in the world you're not gonna get fat
you be nothing you know like exactly the
same every time at your age that's not
sure I believe I have the potential of
único muscular man I would TLT I feel in
my heart that I can still be a mesomorph
do it man I want to be the white Cheick
Kongo know you could do that yeah I
think if I really really apply my little
checky checky dude how about our boy
dove last night at the Comedy Store
fantastic oh yeah dome I set them down
because let me talk to you and takes me
out and [ __ ] didn't talk to me for I
don't know 45 and seen him and I spent a
long time for a little hot 45 minute
just a therapy session disappeared and
there it was great dude the best we're
performing together at the at the Laugh
Factory
tonight I'm there what time are you
there the Laugh Factory yeah that's
fantastic I don't know 8 o'clock 8
o'clock show and do all still stand up
so it'll be me but there you are is
Krista to with you on that to hopefully
I went to Leah
hopefully you know Billy likes to watch
me and hold study me how ridiculous is
that by the way that's the craziest that
little rascals things the craziest thing
I've ever seen years now scares me it
freaked me out to you it made me think
like that's what fake faces now oh yeah
they'll be able to do whatever they want
oh no I'm on the 9:45 show daliyah the
noche Ian Edwards Nick Swardson I can't
ever heard it I don't leave a whole lot
of room for you guys bring your oxygen
Scott will be subdued how scary is this
video that the fakin Stein at at fakin
Stein made hmm if they're able to do
this with Rogen
Brogan's face is whatever your liking I
guess that's him with me it's [ __ ]
spot-on that's crazy well right now I
think about like what could like the
voice isn't the same but yeah you can
just show up I don't even know what's
gonna happen now you wanna watch it he's
in technics already I mean this is a
fall together how do they do it with the
lips picture mouth I know it's freaky
[Music]
insidiousness our girl SES and it looks
like my brother Rogan is the worst
little girl growing be the worst [ __ ]
of all time even worse [ __ ]
he's nathan positive or strange so he's
gay he's just got the most masculine
face do you see who the kids are look at
the Kevin Hart [ __ ] Alex Jones and
Eddie Bravo
oh is that I don't see that yeah how do
they do the eyes I'm not like those guys
in Venice Beach way up there you are in
the back take you on a picnic tomorrow
excuse don't you feed my soul I can
doctor fakin Stein at doctor fakin Stein
as the gentleman who made this let me
just do a whole movie like who thought
say
swimming day that's astonishing
that's [ __ ] very strange very scary what
they can do take was that scene shot in
the Venice canals is that yes Wow yes
shot in Venice shot that scene in Venice
yeah I'm sure they'd shut the movie no
way huh and Bill Cosby bought the entire
the entire show and basically shelved it
because he thought it was racist Little
Rascals yeah why cuz the black kid
yeah alfalfa and stuff and it was a time
when you know black people were you know
he was a homey in the movie yeah but in
a subordinate kind of very stereotypical
way and so did he buy Looney Tunes and
shelve that too no but he bought he
bought The Little Rascals and and that's
why you've never seen The Little Rascals
again he uh yeah he said I'm gonna buy
this and it's never gonna be put out
there again
a lot of people had problems with it cuz
it was such a masterpiece and a lot of
other ways like yeah music
the stories and every sure this is such
a masterpiece but yeah I didn't know
whoa yeah they said no what a prick well
you know at the same time it was done at
a time when black people were portrayed
in not a very flattering didn't want
that they keep going like that's their
kids that's right I get it
alfalfa was also if I was kind of a
black you news I wanna use that that
short typical thing and he was like I
don't want this [ __ ] mmm-hmm I can kind
of see cuz kids would see that like what
the [ __ ] black kid yeah his parole also
monies but I'm sick [ __ ] I'm buying it
yeah so well he did I still yeah what's
that wait I seen your tits what's going
on
think about alfalfa oh thing about
alfalfa oh dude who was the how about
there's a lady last night the redhead
very pretty
and I'm like I'm thinking I'm asking
doing like who the [ __ ] is this lady
comedy oh we should went away
no I'm like who is this very pretty
older lady and then finally some random
do come there goes dude this fevers over
ridiculous goes would you like to [ __ ]
the girl from Starship Troopers oh
that's my friend Dina my nose your
friend she's awesome yeah she's going I
went for sure lats on it oh [ __ ] she's
from [ __ ] for years he's been working
forever she's very pretty gorgeous and
smart and cool no Dina you know like I'm
in on Dina ladies and gentlemen for 70
years since 1991 [ __ ] that's how
long I've known her that's cool what do
you want to find any women but I mean
that's that's what's crazy we've did and
she's still hot she's still got very
pretty yeah like you know like last time
I saw her was and oh wow look at this
here last time I saw her was in Starship
Troopers
I'm sure she's worked a ton bring up her
I am yeah she's worth DB a ton she was
she's super pretty and I was like God
where the [ __ ] done early good you don't
even see someone a TV show or movie you
think you know them I said god I feel
bad cuz I don't know her cuz she came up
to me she's like we did you really go on
I was like yeah she was hot as a ki I
did and then she said you should I want
an answer I was like yes I did
performing so and she did Brian like
Brian's on now shake did she do all of
us somehow does this [ __ ] know us yeah
and then she was like we're late we
don't have take it so my god I think
they're getting out she was well I know
Sony can get us in and she just knows
like I don't know this lady yeah she
probably yeah she was in Johnny mnemonic
everything look Beverly Hills 90210
remember that Starship Troopers she's
been dizzy bro yeah she's been working
what does she been doing lately keep
going up chin oh that's a cop she's
still working keep going saw - that's a
resume look at that resume I know
phenomenal keep going to the current
stuff though chin you know that by the
years yeah to an eighteen NCIS yeah
American Horror Story dude yeah she
never stops working always working and
she's kind of voluntarily pulled back a
little bit you know she you get tired
and you want to do other stuff but she
was with this big Russian dude couldn't
look any more like GRU he was on target
if GRU
tonight the comic that's a friend for of
hers from high school yeah exactly
he's a New York yeah he's a Jewish cop
from New York yeah he looks identical to
GRU grooming me
I'm telling you GRU you don't you no one
knows what that is
I'm telling you traps no identical - oh
[ __ ]
and he has that like an accent - New
York our heavies you look that down
kabob best I mean what I mean is if you
look like that you look like that I
didn't see that sir but hold on I'm
talking do you guys know that if you
were to make spot on ref if you were to
make a character a cartoon character
that's him dude he's a really famous
character see grill good yeah I mean
that's a little harsh isn't it we wasn't
handsome it wasn't a bad-looking guy no
you're the groom there's nothing wrong
with that sir
he looked like a thug you look like a
tough New York cop look I grow kids
there I'm not ready to say that that's
the case I'll see the problem with it
well I got friendly look he looks
friendly there yeah let's say it's a bad
thing I think brews awesome huge hit I
don't I don't like how you're talking
all right and I don't like how you're
feigning naivete all right all right I
think it's a good thing to look like
real that's like when Chris D'Elia this
this guy I know who's a porn director
well and he called me up and said hey
your boy Chris D'Elia is performing I
want to go see him can you get me
tickets and I said I met this I don't
have I go I don't know it's sold out no
I he shows up I guess anyway and he's
got his girls and the girls who Chris
said and the girls where the girls were
massaging me and but so thanks Brian and
I was like I don't you know I don't die
said nothing and he goes and and we'll
Seth said what does she look like he
said she looked like a regular girl a
girl they'd see I don't know around in
Kmart it was very interesting apparently
she was a porn star and not that
attractive that was his way of kind of
saying it and I feel like you're doing
that right now with GRU I feel you know
not gonna feel like that was a terrible
story well but I feel like you're being
you're saying that he's very
unattractive I'll not see her I'm not
saying it was attractive okay I know it
seems all attractive I think you look
like GRU if you like grew great I
thought is it I feel like you know
I don't I'm not money to us are you get
pictures dude if I'm gonna make a
cartoon baby stretching in that
direction
100 percent what would my cartoon be Ren
& Stimpy you'd be the little chihuahua
and I'd be the big whatever I think he's
a cat right wonder but how do you get to
be a cat and I have to be a [ __ ]
Chihuahua I'll rather be a dog than any
cat ya see I'm the fat one on on the
yeah I'm the one on the right I'm pretty
sure he's a cat and the guy in the
laughs a dog yeah yeah once you know
you're way too old for this but Ren and
Stimpy that calm ones less even watched
it they took it off air that [ __ ] was
funny like my saying well my son gonna
watch it now it's way too too racy oh my
god yeah Ren Stimpy was intense dude
hmmm emotionally unstable Chihuahua and
Stimpy a good-natured yet dim-witted cat
Ren Stimpy dude there's that like Beavis
Butthead beat somebody at the movie was
on the other day my son was like oh it's
this much a little bit like ah man die
see when I watch beavis and butt-head
they had a dog oh don't do that again
and if you do it again I'm gonna I'm
gonna put myself I'm gonna come at you
oh yeah remember I said even bad head I
was watching it yeah they had a dog on a
leash
okay and it was in the road and a car
came along ran it over and ran it over
and it was a spot on the road and I went
I went oh I know I have to watch this
now and that's what got me hooked on
Beavis and buzz on ran over a dog
yes stories are annoying me today well
your [ __ ] sneezing is annoying me
dude I sneeze bro no you don't do that
welcome to the Jess story know when I
sneeze I say welcome to the jungle do it
while you sneeze that's one to the jo
ujong you want to [ __ ] somebody up of
right before they sneeze go bless you
and it takes that their mind off what
they're doing they can't sneeze you know
done that No
it's a really dirty trick that sounds
like a great trick hey tell us about the
time much abusive Butthead and one of
the doctor ran over you like I can he
kept watching this that's what that's
what got me forever it actually never
been done in the cartoon hey remember
the time when Chris D'Elia those two
girls showed me describe them as regular
girls hey man that was cool I was making
I was making a reference tear to your
eye looked a veiled your veiled insult
cat while you tell that she was staring
at the wall because she was learning
learning educating I'm supposed to be
somebody head don't come back like why
not do a revamp of that Mike judge Mike
judge is too busy doing this show called
Silicon Valley I mean mmm I think it
shows over that's not Silicon Valley no
it's coming back I just I just saw the
two stars of it spoke to them and worked
with go to Silicon Valley chin wall cuz
the kind homeboy left from Silicon gamit
they're coming with the comic TJ Miller
he left in the hide oh he's so good yeah
he's great but I don't know why he left
because it's gone back it's awesome so
let's what's it say though chin oh dami
just put canceled just to see season six
yeah I shoot right behind the Goldberg
so I know this Barry in Silicon Valley
bearing up I saw the pilot of Barry I
wasn't that thrilled did you see it no I
haven't seen it but I love I love that
actor yeah he's great
people dig it down and want a shitload
of awards did you watch the first
episode of G ot
you mean Game of Thrones East I got
thirty minutes in I fell asleep a little
slow a lot a lot of loose ends to tie up
a lot of those categories yeah so we'll
see very slow I need more white waters a
little more fighting white waters we're
coming in so is the zombie dragon and
the other dragons aren't eating we don't
know mombi's though there's no they're
zombies dragon nope white Walker dragon
all right white Walker dragon undead
dragon white Walker drag undead dragon
there's scary though very scary the
question is this
I thought your the graphics looked a
little lame this first one when the
adult when the dragon if I was like that
[ __ ] man wasn't ya budget cuts like all
this time sorry Todd Feldman all this
time and then I don't know like I you
know I've watched season six and seven
leading up to season eight just to
refresh my memory so I didn't need all
that who blah that they [ __ ] to the
beginning I knew my [ __ ] and then when I
got some like I I don't know well I just
dragons aren't eating as much as they
usually do
she was what did they eat oh you know
what I love it they want I love when she
was if you want a halt by one she want a
queen earn it yeah I'm every chick ever
was like word and then post on Instagram
what happens in this in this show
she [ __ ] the doop five minutes later
that's real life that's right
that's [ __ ] that Larry yes that's how
guy I don't know about you I find her
insanely attract super attract I mean I
just think she's incredible yeah also
the queen of the Dragons can get it I
are though I like Cersei more than I
like her too
well I like both of them I also like the
the redhead who just came out such as
horrible depression sophie Turner Santa
uh yeah
oh she does have bad depression yeah
she's gorgeous the red the Red Queen
who's that one who ends up dying who was
controlled fire and she was always naked
she well Melisandre oh no you know a
black girl
well that's who's the black she's a
British normal drop she was in uh one of
the more recent fast and furious movies
chin up chin tucked in hot black no I
know what doesn't that game with the
booze oh I don't mind that you did a
girl top left raucous but yes sir she's
somehow Jesus Christ when she's in fast
furious
I don't watch respite from Psalm 36 but
I'll watch some dragons with this black
chick you ain't talking about bras ooh
dragging the black chicks you guys are
confused
I love hair like that curly don't say
like that it looks like it looks like
grapes looks like she's wearing a head
from their shoe grapes like that black
grapes what's her name chin
Natalia Manuel let's get that nose like
those nose I hate those two you know I
like the dot here Lee to the dot here
thank you
the bullring don't have anything yeah
what are you doing at the bullring let's
get rid of that you yeah there you got
there's a few signs that you know
someone's gonna have depression or daddy
issues for a chick it's the nose ring
all right there's gonna be some serious
issues who ground unfold here yeah four
dudes you know that have depression of
that face tattoos yeah I'll have some
darkness of your face tattoos right
that's right if there's a little in
front of their name little uns little
fur lil little Slurpee yeah mmm yeah
said eyebrows on in that one yeah I
prefer the thinner eyebrows those are
Dickies I'm crazy about giant eyebrows
not crazy about Bryan Callen eyebrows
yeah your dad has some bushes Wow you
could you could he could use his
identify can I use ficus I was gonna say
my kisses yeah my dad's my brother keep
people out yes um Jesus Christ she's hot
but yeah that first episode of Game of
Thrones
I understand they got a lead into it and
there's a lot of loose ends and
characters meaning for the first time
but I fear that I fell asleep for a
reason I've never fell asleep before
anyone you ever
I fell asleep that's my favorite show
yeah and I was like all right well we'll
see but seeing it better for me who the
[ __ ] is that who she wholeness is that
take it easy mini
zoom in come on dude take it easy just
zoom in check give the guy a break
I don't know who the [ __ ] that is man
you look like that sounds like you're
not taking any [ __ ] from da man who is
that guy he wears a shirt meruchan I'll
find out yeah she found a good man you
find out tomorrow take it easy
whoo boyfriend is said to have you know
what I think she's Jewish and black or
something
she's like Eritrean stun guessing my
guess is she's Jewish and and like
Ethiopia there I said it
I think she's from heaven
Devin Anderson she's dating him [ __ ]
that Gavin
oh she's a Pisces what's up girl oh me
too
really oh she's from the UK yes so is my
mom on the UK see what her nationality
like what she's actually our ethnic
origins are I'm gonna say what I'm gonna
say Jewish in Ethiopian um say Egyptian
Blas a white white one parents white the
others it's my guess is British English
Oh Dominican English you were close
Brian not bad Dominican anyway you're
super close though yep we're March
babies you know God is so much in common
hey come on take it easy dude did your
into dragon she's um into drag she's in
the sensitive watch Game of Thrones I
watch Game of Thrones come on didn't
breathe air I breathe air I feel like
you're really looking for you know half
Dominican but it's only up from here for
Game of Thrones though I think it's
gonna if I think skater I think said I
hope so what if what if all of them were
just duds let's be honest that fours
episode you like off yeah yeah what if
all eight were like that well would it
be such it's definitely gonna happen
would be such a shame
yeah there's give me two or three that
are just heaters heater either spread
it's gonna be episode five six seven its
God look somebody's got to be somebody's
got to win the game the throne and
that's the question who do you think
really good because it's seven unit it's
now they got to defeat the White Walkers
all coming together well yeah but then
after they defeat the White Walkers
remember there's still Cersei who's got
her claim there's still a lot going on
yeah
but the number one priorities beating
the white wall right for now that's a
big deal for now but as with every
revolution with the accept what do they
forever with the White Walkers no and
they all just fit in can't do that dude
one happy family you're not [ __ ]
looking they live with you god I wish
out a dragon you do it'd be kind of cool
fly around a fire-breathing monster
they definitely do they exist did they
do you guys watch Game of Thrones
Cherica no yep [ __ ] you don't watch any
what do you watch dude what do you watch
chin do your you're burning again Todd
oh did not answer that I'm answered is
that a man sir you're putting a lot of
pressure on it let me let me hold on
that's that well asking what he does
yeah yeah I do and I gotta speak look at
Tony this weekend yeah clean this place
okay I know how to speak to him all
right would you watch because I don't
have your pitying aggressive like he's
not gonna respond to that watch chin how
you doing man everything all right I'm
good now anybody look great I love that
you're wearing a hat as usual you can't
I like your new style
um do you watch do you watch do you have
any shows that you like to watch i watch
a lot of stuff on YouTube like what then
hey hey hey you've got it on so babe I
don't have it in your sidekick in this
good cab I know a lot back you know
Justin we're gonna get one with this
psycho gentian sorry about him against
okay you know what it is yeah I
apologize
he's cold but he's also hot yeah no I
apologize things asked him again um how
is how is your still over well you do
you still over in Koreatown
no he's in downtown fantastic right I
forgot about that
what what do you watch other than
YouTube do you watch anything other than
YouTube I go online you go online oh man
I'm getting you turn it right in your
backyard
yeah you got bad bad I'm actually gonna
just answer the [ __ ] question like
what would you watch those Amazon Prime
yeah what do you watch on amazon prime i
herman Survivorman survivor me it's a
slow show and there's no new ones you
know this you know what what do you
watch on youtube bro fishing videos
fishing videos fishing videos you might
be the boy it's gonna play yeah so you
live downtown
your sings gonna take a special lady to
put up with this [ __ ] there I'm watching
there's fishing any particular kind of
fish will they catch them and they cook
them so you watch also goes everywhere
they cook them
everybody can you hit me in the face so
I can take that yes yeah you want some
hormones yeah all caught up all caught
up I've been watching a bunch of
conspiracy theories on it oh really like
in let's not spoil alert because I heard
DirecTV leaked episodes 1 & 2 on
accident yeah a couple hours before it
was supposed to even air so a couple
people got a hold of the first few
episodes yeah and apparently the second
episode script is out online as well oh
[ __ ] did you look at it no I stay away
from it I say what's the conspiracy
theories well there's a couple uh about
how everything ends like how Cersei dies
who kills her who the night king is all
those little things well balls deep
balls even it you know there's some
podcasts just dedicated Game of Thrones
well you know what life is too short to
be in a podcast or listening to one on
The Game of Thrones
I'll watch the show and buy on it though
yeah great
congratulations well it's like obviously
it's one of the biggest podcasts of all
time but serial remember had that murder
case they can get kid and then the you
see the series on HBO was so boring some
things just don't correlate you know is
that the that's not the odd not saying
yeah it is okay is that boring uh it's
almost not nowhere near as gives a
podcast not even remotely I found out
that the DNA test came out not positive
so it wasn't his DNA was not there I
don't know man we don't know too much
about the subject there's a ton of Game
of Thrones podcasts oh yeah that's how
it it's Game of Thrones would be a show
of all time that's what a lot of people
say it's either that or The Sopranos how
many people do we think is watching Game
of Thrones chin to say do they have any
idea because HBO is off see subscribers
but then you can watch like I don't have
HBO but I have said 17.4 Nielsen million
people that's big nothing that's
accurate though cuz think of all the
people who share HBO counts or use their
relatives or stream it illegally online
a price to double that huh
somewhere in the ballpark I think well
Nielsen also is only one so Nielsen is
one rating right it's one rating and
also it's when you have a Nielsen box
okay so so they are balancing you they
put Nielsen boxes out there so that's
not a good represent
it's all way more than that yeah they do
an algorithm where they can display
space it out but you the Nielsen ratings
are so out of I would assume it's around
30 yeah maybe more yeah argue argue the
most popular show on TV there you go
yeah I I've never heard of a show that
low where everyone like if you mention
it everyone watches it
we're like remember just not too long
ago I was one of those non-believers
yeah go dragons yeah I'm all set 30 and
I knew and you guys and then I got my
little tickle up my [ __ ] for dragging
little tonight [ __ ] what was the what
was the turning point you said let me
give you nothing to be doing at oh I
don't know nothing so I need a show I
thought yeah these [ __ ] won't shut
about Game of Thrones click all right
I'm in yeah I'll get message in my toe
I'm in I stabbed watch Sopranos either I
still got that in the UI I can't that's
so much Breaking Bad well and what
define for me to talk to you you know
what the thing is so when everyone like
nursing black panther I've ever seen
meaning the Avengers when everyone goes
oh dude you got to see this I don't see
it it's better if you just don't tell me
well you know the fact that you haven't
seen Breaking Bad and I watch one
absolutely bad - the greatest shows ever
no I know I watched one X outbreak
violent I got it oh my god but I got it
Oh Breaking Bad it is for me so good
Breaking Bad is probably gun to my head
to me the best show ever
Game of Thrones says hold my dragon the
original extras funny show I mean the
original office with Ricky Gervais funny
show ever the most the best show I've
ever seen ever as far as I can go as far
as the funny wise Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
well most original they're both great
but as far as original and like 18 to 36
demographic
nothing better notice I hate seal it so
I don't there she'd seen it you hey
don't ever seen I always though don't
know you haven't seen bringing batter
for soprano so you can't really talk to
me right now
always up but here's the thing Always
Sunny in Philadelphia is season 17
that's impressive kid Harrington
apparently is very short kid yeah all
that small one the small one is not the
taller one he's made Joe Jonas where the
[ __ ] his name is no the main guy Jon
Snow
Oh Jon Snow yeah Jon Snow's small at 5/8
think the things you so I solved them
all at the Golden Globes same same
height don't say makes me mad don't say
that because people always I saw that
all at the Golden Globes you know the
big girl who said the night you can
fight all Breana tart girl bro Brian
she's a giant but hold on hold it bigger
than me sir what she was in heels and I
went well yeah it's a dragon and I get
scared
but it was her now Kate look at how
small kid is there next there what's his
or her my girl thought to call John Snow
though you know Jon Snow
Jon Snow is shorter than five eight and
I you you guys say bye oh he's a lot
about the red hair she's engaged to Joe
Jonas Joe Jonas yeah because I was
hearing today how she suffers from
depression yeah oh [ __ ] yeah you know
what you know she got it from I'm sorry
to interrupt his that blonde girl the
one you're talking about she's the about
big bird in the middle hey big bird down
back hey big bird out of a shot hey big
bird we're trying to hit Jon Snow here
yeah what are you ready when I was when
I walked the [ __ ] red carpet and I
was like this was when Black Knight came
out I was on a TV show when I went
because my buddy would directed a Black
Knight with Martin Lawrence Marlon was
the height of his power Hall yeah movie
bro when hit Brahm but when he came when
he came on the red carpet hahaha house
in the way husband seat height I'm not
exaggerating I swear gonna crush you
they were like listening that the
paparazzi you know those guys who take
the pictures they go get the [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of the way get the [ __ ] out
yeah I mean they starts gonna I got so
she'll suck I went they go get away yeah
good I like and I like oh I don't want
to be here and I want to see the movie I
got so mad that I I stormed off and I
socialize the [ __ ] night I damn
embarrassing there's a pecking order
David bear isn't getting the [ __ ] they
didn't know who I was get out [ __ ] you
scream get the [ __ ] out the way it
happened to me at the Golden Globes when
they're like we do you want to like the
red carpet I'm like I guess anything's
always awkward also Lady gaga
Bradley Cooper like everyone's here I
just feel like it should be on them like
well there's been some requests made
Susan a giant so I'm like okay so I'm in
a dominant crust velvet and remember
tuxedo coat and I'm walk-in and then do
you you wanna do the fashion cam like
I've always wanted to it yeah it'd be
great and then I'm like doing it and
they're like set everything up and then
someone yells out Lady Gaga and then
literally it was like I was a [ __ ]
mushroom on the floor of course your way
stop all the cameras like let's just
yeah you get it
laters for by the way season we get it
later yeah I mean maybe just go this
side of the okay not to stand like a
[ __ ] bouncer while she [ __ ] this
elegant gown 70 people and just shut the
thing down shut it down
get the [ __ ] my eyes for your baby and
how about how about 41 do you have
someone who goes Bryan Callen and
there's a piece of paper I don't do it
Bryan Callen and there was a click and
there was by the roll Brendon Schwab I'm
like new a nut job she was Schwab and
then I go oh it's Tori no I actually
went like you saw it I hate to do this
it's actually it's shop shoes Schwab I'm
like story of my Hollywood life sir and
when I did fat actors it was a big show
I'm chewing gum oh wow that's a much
like an energy and my pollicis girls
like this year's give me that so hey
just spit he had an idea I was like ah
sorry well she was so annoying
yeah Oh your boy from Sunny in
Philadelphia was actually in episode 1
Rob yeah yeah they're friends
really I was there when they really
first met on a private jet and I [ __ ]
up and I didn't know who they were and I
went wow all we said in Philadelphia cuz
they're talking about shooting in
Ireland season seven of Game of Thrones
and this at the time I don't want show
tell the story before and they're
talking about it and gone with Rob in
the front seat more time not always
sunny and they hear them timeout Dublin
in the back girl
Jesus Christ man oak is always sudden
he's been getting [ __ ] for selling out
whatever it's going mainstream and I got
man he goes shooting in Dublin geez
really did sell out the two creators
Game of Thrones go there in the middle
of time saver someone way more important
me go hmm
excuse me mega you and now the whole
[ __ ] private plane is listening to me
I go oh he Sonny really sold out like
your own said cuz you guys didn't Dublin
out and they go no no we're taught where
did the creators of Game of Thrones yeah
no we're shooting season seven in Dublin
that's cool man
and just the whole plane was like [ __ ]
that's hilarious
Wow that's him he's hilarious
yeah is actually is a writer writer
creator director of always sunny
seventeen seasons and actor main
character actor Wow
and he's married to Kate Olsen who's
also the star of Always Sunny in
Philadelphia something else and she's a
big actress as well there they are the
boys I saw him on the ride off a bikini
it's one of only people I know right
it's one of the only Thomas he's with
his son went dude I [ __ ] love your
show know what thanks man yeah that was
it it's only communication had with him
yeah that did dude that's it bro hmm
great story thanks man
thanks dude that dude right there I just
worked with [ __ ] yeah dude right there
from guy yeah I was oh she's uh Silicon
Valley master alright yeah he and the
other guy the star the main guy
he's funny but they did the music video
with me I wasn't in the scene with him
perfect good story by here at that time
I was said this is years ago we ever
having we have awful stories they
remember that time when I went to the
premiere Freddy for that one movie and
you got edited out of it basically which
one was that about last night oh yeah
I'd be modern suits my Newton week um
and they forgot to tell Brock Hart okay
Eddie's him out of the movie happens all
he was in just like a shot at the bar
and he cheers the guy in the mind's eye
here we go and like happens Adrien Brody
Thin Red Line written out of the movie
and it out didn't know it yet don't keep
him examples we're talking about you
Frank guerrilla biggest thing ever
what was it with that Minority Report
with Tom Cruise Steven Spielberg he's
there for two months it's like I was
like dude you made it heute there's one
scene where you see him in a hat hit at
police helmet he's here for two months
he's there for two months
I mean it's like the biggest thing
because I seek imagine getting a bit
moving like that [ __ ] I did bro I went
what me goes with Tom Cruise I'm like
why it's so big before this is so long
ago
so long I'm Frank we're like holy [ __ ]
dude it's like it's such a long cruise
and and I go to the movie to see my boy
Frank and this I've never I don't have a
friend who's been in a huge movie with
Tom Cruise like a big deal and I go
there and I'm watching and I'm waiting
and I see a cop go in the mall go look
over turn and he's got a helmet and he
goes that's it that's it yeah and and
comes back and that was all he was and
apparently Frank was in the movie and he
goes like this he saw how the story was
going anyway oh no dude I think but I
think I'm gonna have Frank because on
tax collectors Shia LaBeouf yeah you
know I mean that I was there for I've
shot some scenes I remember and I got a
cowboy hat you know cartel member and
yeah and they were like all right so he
put this really take yourself it on
there all day shooting and then it was
like this main fight scene and they give
me a hat and then some like whatever
like producer like assistant to the
producer they can't put this mask on and
like I'm not wearing a master in the big
fight scene so I just put it to the side
and I'm shooting here god Oh big man
did you give you a mask on it I just
sold her in the river a mask I don't
think so I don't I don't think I have a
mask on he goes you definitely do you
definitely can we get a mask and the
girl comes out she's like dick I put it
on you see and that you might see me
have a maps like this a Red Devil mess
you see my eye or an extra thanks for
the time no experience no but then if
you know because I'm like a cartel
member you know a bodyguard - the main
boss yeah so I'm in with a gun the whole
time and then my buddy saw cut of it I
go well did they put me and he goes and
he's trying to be nice because here's
the thing so anyone who knows you just
gonna didn't recognize you and you know
like your friends are definitely in oh
damn that's brother an x-ray in the room
but the rat spot it's fighting meetup
for the ceiling that's cool man yep cool
could've told you that by the way that's
how happens hilariously and but this is
that's your first movie but Frank had
been acting for an image and Frank had
been in there we've been in the trenches
for at least 12 years so when he got it
it was like you have read you arrived
all right there you are there you are
there you're not there you are there
you're not so funny that's the business
we saw his laugh you'd see a dude in a
movie me and my friend you'd see a dude
in a movie and he'd come up and go you
guys want some more coffee
cool yeah all right great and we go five
auditions that took five that was five
auditions and they give him that part
like it's just oh it's just a beast man
always a [ __ ]
Jessica Chastain's got something to say
these are legit actors guys that cut out
of yeah well so well you know you know
uh who's the big boy
what's this the Polaris kid big fat kid
in Superbad oh no Joe you know Jonah
Hill in Django his character you know
where he's like my wife spent all day
make these [ __ ] hoods for you
you don't ask me minds are you mines are
your from nothing remember like to get
all mad during the KK seen his character
had like it was a huge huge storyline
they edited the whole thing out but he
was he's shot as much as Leonardo
DiCaprio didn't they just took that
whole all of it out was like I'm not
gonna use it
Wow I mean what can you do ban not much
you can do if they decide to edit uh no
because they're did the story is there
you know it's about the moon you're an
actor and grand-scale
the one thing you want to piss todd
phillips off in a movie make make the
[ __ ] movie about yourself you go
ahead and do that make what your
characters thing about you it's about
the movie [ __ ] guy complaining about
you know they they've got the monkey
there and charged at the gwelf when i'm
shooting the gun and then the the
[ __ ] you know you know that that's
what's the case and the guy goes well my
monkey doesn't really want the charges
tacos Wolin this is a million dollar day
you knew that we had charges they're not
loud but they have to make some noise
and hey guys yeah but my monkeys i don't
know if my monkeys gonna like this hell
no he goes shoes me all bad i can see
him in the guy goes well I don't want my
monkey to go deaf oh okay well so here's
the problem with that I mean you're
telling me that now we're doing these
800 latest articles and your monkey is
not gonna go death so don't say that
it's not gonna go deaf don't make the
movie about you and your monkey I don't
man in the year he's right it's like
everybody everybody had to shut up and
it habit was very interested in the
monkey went death the thing he doesn't
like yeah it wasn't that loud the monkey
was fine and by the way there's lots of
regulations on that but it
like it isn't Thailand but it was like
you don't tell me the monkeys couldn't
go down Thailand there's a million month
because he likes he likes monkeys don't
get him here don't get in his head he's
trying to make a movie yeah
do you guys yeah bro what if so if your
film like like say your film you know
you don't expect it ya know what are you
Brian
what if you're in a movie you're
actually an ochre or like you didn't get
royalties on you don't get rid of T's
don't like the hangover oh yes I do only
hundreds of thousands of dollars
hundreds of families still owe hundreds
of thousands of dollars I've probably
made yeah I don't know if he's joking
enough I'm being dead serious
Oh from royalties in my star rated movie
of all those humongous or number two but
I get a bit you barely in it oh it
doesn't matter
I'm every time it's played I get
residuals everyone does I so I made
probably two grand for the day and once
it became that big and still is that big
and hangover 2 I've probably made I'll
get you the exact number I'll call me
but does everyone get that money anyone
with a student it ends on how much of a
role you had but I was in two scenes in
the hangover I was in two scenes in the
sex like one so you know you can its hey
to the point like you in it you know I
had and I had a real part in mine but
what about in uh like old school when
you're the waiter I've seen I bet you
I've probably seen realistically if you
really tell you it all up if you told me
I made over a money ran for that for
just that one pound I surprised I don't
know cuz he came out years yeah I mean
you're talking about a movie that came
out twenty years ago much money Will
Ferrell how you use the gift that keeps
giving but maybe more I mean I you know
with the floors the Goldbergs plays six
times in all over the world right every
day kids in syndication I make a lot of
money off that cuz your main character
yeah
you know it's it's it and it's all great
team I knew nineties I did I never count
on it but then my business manager will
be like your residuals this month I'm
like [ __ ] I forgot about that it is the
one good thing about being an actor if
you've been acting as long as I have I
now I still get five cents from West
Wing
I'll get check alone twenty five cents
or two cents yeah literally
look
what about from that TV we use I God get
a dollar 50 for a minute
I get a check once we offer three
dollars you know depends and then it all
trails off to like that you know after a
while it's not play so if you're Tom
Cruise when they keep playing his movies
they're like Brendan I was thinking
about Brendan Fraser the other day
shoutout to Brendan Fraser one of the
original Brendan's Yes No the mummy gets
played all the times making make money
off that a lot of money nothing I've
seen was that guy do for work now cuz
he's not if they worked out a point
system on that that's another thing
where you making real money what is that
guy doing for work it's not easy I think
he's getting back into acting nicest guy
on the [ __ ] yet he had a show on a
effect he's such a [ __ ] good guy I've
met him once dude and he was such an
awesome you want see a crazy picture
look at him when he was George of the
jungle or in the mummy yeah he's a great
big guy but he's put on some weight yeah
father time went Yoda yeah well he's
also put on a lot of weight it looks
like it dude look at that die me always
a stud stuck at him dude yeah the shape
straight up model oh your motto and then
go to uh you know six every bit of six
for sure and I have it on good authority
that he's got our [ __ ] pipe yeah sure
I got it on good authority he's got a I
guess yeah I guess what's that say
Brendan Fraser reveals why I dipped out
four years I guess he was obviously
sexually molested by director something
like that he's done something like
grabbing nuts
that's a grown man if you grab my nuts
I'm not gonna call so I don't have to
use Dave Chappelle's reference I don't
know if this business is for you if that
stops you I was gonna say leave someone
sucked my dick at the store tomorrow
night now if you're a grown man you're
grown man so what are you talking about
police put on some weight though he was
a beautiful young man yeah that's and a
good guy man I've heard from so many
people he sucks for dude I'm a fan he's
the original Brendan oh yeah name
another Brendan before brendan fraiser
camera i can't name another one I can't
rewrite Oh
[ __ ] father time father Tom Hume a
lot of sugar ow
Oh cheer you sugar and booze and father
so what I like my song sugar and booze
and father time will take the best of
their man turn them into you why it's
coming for us that's what's not me I'll
find it get my lids lifted you got his
lids lifted I'll get my lids lifted
right now dude that's so [ __ ] up man
it hurts it hurts [ __ ] without the
brendan fraiser though you made a little
bit of a comeback with the sea of kids
and fake yeah but that's real that's
real real laughter second he ate the
mummy there's that's that's some people
ate a lot of food dude I'm one bad break
from turning to Brendan Fraser I'm one
sad always business frightening your
inner Brendan Fraser
oh yeah me neither Fraser is just like
those Rock'em Sock'em robots you stay in
shape but I know we're out ten and hold
on I work out seven days a week yeah
because like to eat you have one bad
break from turning to brilliant all the
cake won't you sure if you have cake
yeah it's a type I like is a little
Susie's birthday cake whatever you want
you like it sweet yeah a lot Suzie's I
know Suzie's the item Suzie all right
and you'll either all you'll eat the
cake the entire cake so you don't call a
pizza you know go this is too sweet you
just keep it on no I can't get sweet you
let you know sweet tea yeah regular tea
to me dude yeah yeah and you can t boy
to you know you can t to thighs
dee do you hide your candy your candy
boy from your from your girl does she
know that you have not live in them my
truth you living your truth leave at
home yeah they know the deal really yeah
sometimes I'll just squirt honey into my
mouth uh-huh let's walk by honey and
just go oh okay okay let's me dude
that's why I work out on the Palatine so
food really does destroy him Marla no I
bought body shaming is good for you my
show by Marlon Brando when he was young
and and and no we got over marlon brando
he's [ __ ] he was fat but the thing is
russian huh that might be depression for
him
brendan fraiser oh did you but do back
to the get Game of Thrones dime piece
the redhead what's her name the
character name don't care about a real
name what's the Kanta Santa Santa Santa
Santa Santa Santa was saying she would
get online grudge frustratingly hot
she's in the x-men series - she's Jean
Grey how can I ask you a question that
was like a favorite character ask your
questions to dr. Jean Grey but budget
jack off the man not ready can I ask you
a question you jacked off to the night
Carla no how is the bad day the body
dope sure I'm positive I've seen it dude
okay
hey she's awesome dude my boy Jonas can
[ __ ] anybody and pick Songza here's
the thing though cuz I secretly want her
body to not be there so I can lose my
she's like guy Steve so her thing is is
she said she would get online this is
crazy she get online after episodes and
read all the hateful comments making fun
of her body and how she's a terrible act
why would she said she'd get on said
feel like she wasn't good actor why
would she do that to off [ __ ] why would
you read that dumb [ __ ] I don't watch it
well she's died when she was so young oh
man she's 12
do not read any of this [ __ ] I know why
would you get 12 when she said she was
12 yeah everyone like grew the [ __ ]
she's 12
her younger the girl who played her
younger sister was 11 that big blonde
started she was 5 7 6 11 a season 8 6 11
crazy right does that make Joe Jonas
yeah then boys can sing she's um
delicious yeah she's your type dude whoo
look at the little guy
he's a little guy it'll be a bummer
she's a big girl and why is she not how
tall she's five six she's not big it's
not big at all well I denied that's
pretty tall he's only five seven Oh sing
by 7:00 don't say that same 5/7 how big
is uh Jonas's I've worked Lee means
bigger than five six that's ridiculous
no that's Oh Nick Jonas is uh every bit
of five nine I've spent I've spent a lot
of time with him right next to him he's
he's definitely definitely not five six
you guys that's ridiculous yeah well
it's not he's every bit of five nine it
hides the trigger short you know I'm
tall much taller than Nick Nick and tall
and I'm tall actually but he's not that
short he's definitely short five nine no
legit five nine I spent too much time
think so dude I take people in no I take
him in uh I give him five seven or five
eight
I'll give him five five five eight
looking five it not five nine five it
he's not five six the boys can sing yeah
they're back together
I know damn he's with Demi Lovato
they're close to the same right there
what should I be worried Jamie Lovato
used to date Joe they're best friends
Oh how's she doing she had a tough time
of it died yeah that makes she's doing
better
she's staying off social media after
she's gotten out of rehab so good so sue
me you know [ __ ] with people man and
with the wrong thing if you don't have
the right mentality yeah let's go some
current events sure it's crying about it
you like current event yeah when uh the
run event it actually Nick I remember
him saying something to a comment or two
that talked about his height what do you
say Oh IRA died to her that he clapped
back yeah yeah like a very good way I
forgot what he did he clap back you know
what that means you old [ __ ] no
responded yeah he's a he's five six
that's ridiculous it's not ridiculous it
is it's nice not near so is Nick Jonas
responds to a fan oh that's all I said I
didn't need to start to take that Oh cuz
he took a picture when the guy said some
mom being short yeah
and he goes oh there it is oh well
that's my boy Jonathan Tucker great guy
yeah he's a [ __ ] hell of an actor
Jesus he's a great actor
grow up um you know they gotta take a
picture of them you need a few more
inches bro oh yeah so patient but you
need a few more inches cuz he's short
he's five six
he said he played
we need some more matters brah I didn't
need to stop to take that picture with
you just rude very rude see I only talk
about something I used to trigger for me
for me yeah then what did I say to me
every time you're short you're much
taller and I thought you're totally well
cuz I'm big more standing next to the
giant yeah yeah and I'm Elise it all
others then I get this a lot from guys
dammit I thought was taller than you
weird every time all right I think
that's all I'm talking what do you got
so a soccer team has banned their
teammates from taking pictures with
Drake until after the season FairPoint
cuz he has struck again it's a fair
point anything he likes they do
typically don't win I had a bit of a
Drake streak with MMA for a while I'm
off of it now yeah I've been bigger so
when he picks somebody he jumps on like
the you know like Kentucky freakin max
Holloway you know all these guys Connor
Toronto LeBron anything that's hot he
jumps on they lose mmm-hmm it's the
Drake curse yeah get away from Drake
curse yeah people are saying that the
Drake curse is a lot worse than the
Kardashian curse production curse is
pretty rough yeah yeah unless you're
Travis cot and keep on busting nuts bro
what they back together what they seen
out together I don't keep up you got
stopped cheating on it I know that he's
are ugly dude you compared him to
someone uh I think he is the less
attractive brother of ASAP rocky oh
that's fair a snob rocky is fine
yeah ASAP Rocky is good-looking dude
bring him up I don't know what he said
rocky and then they sat Rocky's a model
dude like Gigi that model should be
looking kid yeah he's good I think
sponsor ID or Versace or some big ass
company no yeah he's a good-looking dude
Travis Scott looks rough by Travis Scott
also used to hook up with Rihanna so
something's going on mm-hmm
that did games strong the dick game is
strong
that's what it is gotta try at getting
up yeah that's Travis guy who looks like
a kid from [ __ ] Sponge Bob Square not
good not good probably got those eyes
some of the Julio's yeah bedroom eyes
I'm a fan though what else we got so a
waitress from Joe's Crab Shack that's
located off of a pier saw a little boy
drowning and she jumped off the pier to
save him
however she hit the sand because it was
low tide and she ended up breaking some
bones and her back and her legs she
could not save the boy and she needs to
be rescued the boy I know the boys
[ __ ] so she basically Jim carried it
from dumb donor like it's okay I'm a
limo driver yeah waiter said Joe Joe's
Crab Shack he's not athletic broke her
basket legs and all of the articles make
it seem so heroic when you first kind of
read into it you're like oh my gosh this
girl it was amazing she just washed
everything to save this little boy and
then you read the details that it wasn't
actually off of the pier where the water
is closer to where the sand is and it's
low tide and so she jumped into that
it's pretty gangster though and then
like look at this how you would know not
to jump anywhere this is on I'm not sure
this is low tide or regular tide but she
literally jumped when I mean look at
this still a badass move even though she
accomplished nothing big at the boat if
her mind is in that yeah if she was
trying to save someone and that's it
then yes that's a great well why else
wouldn't know I'm saying like you think
she was you couldn't think of anything
else but saving that kid then yes but I
mean she should that's the only way
you'd do that and jump off high down all
those bones she should have yelled or
something I don't know that's a high
pier to jump off of that's ballsy of her
I think she just was not thinking at all
I think she was I gotta save the kid
like it's okay I'll work at Joe's Crab
Shack jump jump that's a real jump smoke
her back you live and you learn that you
live and you learn
yeah cuz she probably would compare
Lakes like this kid is probably like I'm
fine
but good on her for trying to save so
much Jesus grace that'll hurt that's low
tide right there what else she get all
right so Justin Bieber was just hit with
a lawsuit for hitting a paparazzi guy
with his truck so what i'ma go yeah this
happened back in 2017 this is actually
the video of him hitting the
photographer with his truck the
photographer says that he didn't want to
go out of his way to sue Justin Bieber
he was actually trying to go through
Justin Bieber's insurance company but he
says that the insurance company was
low-balling him and wouldn't pay were
such him enough and so now he has to go
out of his way to see Justin Bieber for
more money dude because your life
somebody got hurt so you know sue he had
to have surgery on his right meniscus I
never really looked up before from
playing [ __ ] freeze tagging high
school play hit let me see it hit play
goodnight buddy this video is not
working he was leaving Church actually
church at night this is when he got
spiritual yeah I think he's still
spiritual but just did a raptor or to
dodge get out of the way did he mean to
hit that guy
no even even the photographer said like
he doesn't think Justin tried to hit him
it's just that the truck is probably too
big for him to see within his noon spots
but also get out the [ __ ] way mm-hmm
if I'm a judge at least I'm like well
why are you so close to his [ __ ]
truck you know he's leaving right what
are you doing right now you're not
getting a dime you [ __ ] I mean you did
get [ __ ] up isn't he looks like it's
pretty I know we'd get out of the way of
someone's truck yeah there has to be a
little common sense why I agree wait
your photographer invading his privacy
yeah you not getting shot that is
exhausting
everywhere you go cameras that daddy
daddy is a pain in the ass I don't care
what anybody says it's like wants to
live that way it's what you sign up for
though hey probably does she got I'm
sure you're tired of the Jesse Smollett
stuff by now not really of it well
there's some new texts from that woman
Kym Fox who was the Cook County State
Attorney that recused herself because
she knew Jesse Smollett and so she had
her other guy her lead whatever
prosecutor to go after her or take care
of it so these are some released texts
but also pedophile with four victims 10
counts washed-up celebrity cops 16
meaning counts just because we can
charge something doesn't mean we should
and on the day the charges were dropped
Fox texted that she had just spoken with
police superintendent Eddie Johnson
quote laugh out loud he's at the police
recruit event needed to know how to
answer questions from press told him
essentially deferred prosecution paying
10k restitution to the city and
completed community service
he was told we were just dropping the
charges he seemed satisfied with the
explanation except Eddie Johnson was
furious with the decision as was then
mayor rahm emanuel smollett is now being
sued basically everyone that was even on
his side already said yeah he's
definitely up ssin so destruction
wearing actually no I'm saying but we
know this this isn't any anything yeah I
mean you know did you need that to know
that it was gross I just think it's
interesting that the kim fox
PA is literally that in depth and trying
to get him off live of course all right
moving on does someone want a 1.2
million dollars betting on Tiger Woods
and this guy he's a day trader
he's never better on sports ever in his
life and he put $85,000 on that 14 to 1
odds there's something going on with
this right yeah there's something yeah I
had a lot of issues yeah even ubered
with the group uber cuz you wanted to
save two bucks yeah my problem and then
went to like two different casinos they
wouldn't take the bet finally one did by
the way when you don't have money and
you put 85 grand down I'm like what's on
his house $85,000 and Tiger Woods do
mean ass Jesus Christ a 10-year layoff
and it's a 40s son do you got something
going on there sometimes yeah some
you're pretty crazy yeah something well
he want one point see so he's okay he's
okay for now that money second people
like dad tend to always have my
entourage
always did that guy ask him for money
ever go away gonna get you played the
message for me which is hilarious ah did
you deal with her did you deal with it
the way I say came back he came back to
deal with it how I said you should know
I didn't you responded god damn it Brian
doctor did you get money yeah wow you
suck what else you got
alright I want to ask this before I play
it so or even Jonas gets for money
no it's a depressing one but you heard
about that kid being thrown off do you
want to talk about that debris no no I
don't know we're talking the Mall of
America some dude picked up a kid and
threw him off third
right no more yeah randomly you just
picked him up threw him yeah why he uh
I'll just show you the story real quick
- he was crazy
he's definitely crazy there's something
wrong with him yeah so let's see he went
there the day before this is what he
told the investigators after he was
arrested he went there the day before to
the mall looking to kill someone and it
didn't happen he couldn't find someone
the next day he started trying to talk
to girls and kept getting rejected so he
got pissed off and all he saw was that
kid so he decided to throw the kid off
randomly the kid died he's in the
hospital it's like I'm pretty sure
critical cognition right now so I mean
so I guess just showing this like if
you're around those malls or whatever
just make sure to always have your your
kid next to you because there's
crazy-ass people like this and this is a
guy he's definitely has mental issues
now he should it doesn't matter they
should throw him off the top of the roof
he's just not all there he stole my
stuff crazy person just throw him off
the top well I was gonna do it in a
hospital and do what just keep him there
you know you just keep him in it's not a
life for him work for taxpayers throw my
flight like they always say like back in
the day when I had somebody had an
epileptic seizure they hit somebody
saying you were you were you had evil
spirit so they burn you because you're a
witch I think we're gonna find later on
as we learn more about the brain that
this person has a broken computer and
it's broken has to go away you keep them
out of away from people yes right all
right I mean I don't think there's a use
for them in society in any facet I need
you hurt children stressed for you're
willing to throw a five-year-old off of
[ __ ] top of a mall tower that you do
the same to him if we don't have any use
for them we don't how to fix these evil
individuals it's a sickness that's fine
it's an evil sickness that we can't cure
right now yeah so you want waste
taxpayers money and put them where what
do you want to put in prison that's not
gonna help them I was gonna help us well
there are a lot of people killed there
are a lot of people that would agree
with that
what else you got and probably most
people would but then when you get to
down to the legal nitty-gritty you just
put them away yep question it says
hospital right there have to go to let
the holy cow he's definitely go to jail
let the prisoners take care of them they
will you do that to a child good luck
but what what if what bit but what
you're talking about somebody who is not
so love their their own mind so you put
him in a hospital typically it's it's it
that's why we have an insanity plea
where did he know right from wrong is he
that crazy it's a very difficult thing
to prove but here's the thing is he that
out of his mind if he planned this if he
went no that's what were to jail look
around looked around didn't find anyone
he wanted to kill came back talk to
girls
so he's conscious enough to be a
paranoid schizophrenic right so mental
illness is a very he's definitely
mentally ill he's gonna go to jail for
sure and he's like he's 24 years old
which I thought was interesting to you
for some reason
well schizophrenia hits men in their 20s
mmm I say come into illness like that
definitely kill him all right this other
story so this woman whose work works as
a trustee at the Las Vegas school she
just worried did something incorrectly
and by the way they're doing this board
with board meeting to try to resolve
like some racist threats that were
happening at the school so they're
talking to the community about it so you
can say people of color but not color
yes she said coloreds do a lot I'll play
it for you real quick so you can hear to
address these racist social media posts
targeting black students at Arbor View
High School Clark County School District
trustee
she's make actually attract occasionally
an innocuous stage right now but in the
next breath manages to both offense one
is our lack of safety protocols and the
other one is the safety of colored
students in general and then shock
nearly everyone with her apparent lack
of self awareness
these are two different conversations
there's a clear problem with our culture
as several parents head for the door
it's not until she turns off of Mike and
a fellow trustee clues are in that she
appears aware of her misstep I am so
sorry for saying that anyway so is led
races she's just yeah humble she was
ignorant to the fact that doesn't mean
she's bad doesn't
racers trying to help out also over the
benefit of the doubt so very hot so even
more benefit of a doubt all right
she's extremely hard for her let's be
let's be kind let's not make it worse
let's not call a non racist a race he's
not making the world better a better
place by calling a non racist a racist
she made a mistake she put I use I used
a word that I know is extremely hurtful
to a lot of people and for that I'm
deeply sorry I have a friend a very hurt
marginalized community and I wish I
could take it back
oh yeah huge family I'm job please sign
my okay okay well let you know that okay
well I think you've heard the benefits
about you forgiven and it's I get it
like a lot of my lot of women are like a
lot of those black women are like that
you know listen there you go
but people aren't aware that that's just
not being aware and now she is aware
that's how you learn yeah that's how you
learn uh happy sorry please chin this
one well it's just Russell Wilson ha
happy I guess is that giving a sister
that biggest NFL signing ever he's the
richest player of all time biggest kind
of gets contract yeah yeah it is weird
like this video so so the here's that
let me give the context so it took so
what happens Russell Wilson went listen
I'm not reciting until you give me a big
contract his contract was not because
but I'd rather you trade me play for
another team I need a big contract cuz
he's worth it for sure yeah he's only
player on the team he's only reason why
anyone talks about him here's until I
get paid what I'm worth
I'm not doing [ __ ] so went all through
and he gave him a deadline like that
midnight so this videos like right 1:00
in the morning once they resolved it so
you know his wife is here they have a
child together play it this is a bit
early sent after you sign the contract
140 million I think yeah yeah where
other people would be out celebrating
and stuff but easier a Seattle we got a
deal go Hawks
go Hawks I'm gonna see yawn morning
Tommy yeah I go to bed see
okay hey uh hey man hey man easy with
your perfect life it's at sixty million
dollars they just get done that's right
that's 60 million dollars in the bank
after 140 actually means 60 no different
taxes no it doesn't know I've done all
the numbers no okay what do you mean you
got about I do pay taxes to 140 millions
not sixty million is it no it's not okay
so his so so his agent and his lawyer
Commission how much how much in the
library I can tell you this I know Brian
Hill how much the NFL agents take from a
Content percent five percent actually
three percent I don't believe that's
true look that up I believe let's get a
10 percent what do I know if your lawyer
takes five percent what do I know I'm
just telling you that typically a lot of
times they take NFL contracts let's see
maybe your runners managers then there's
agents so he's probably got a manager
you gonna learn no matter what in the
draft right right so it's not like the
NFL it's not like the UFC or with acting
right maybe you're right maybe right but
you still take him he's still got a
lawyer he's still got usually four to
six percent would be high I'd say he's
probably paying altogether with with
everything before we hit taxes I think
his Commission's are at least 10% four
to ten percent okay that's what
but hold on hold on horn except for the
National Football League States an agent
can't receive more than three percent oh
wow so shut your mouth all right cuz
listen I was doing it for basketball but
here's the thing was in the NFL for a
short time
yeah so this like me are you active no
no I mean I I'm I know the bet
basketball we did it for yeah but this
isn't basketball right this would be a
no fell three percent is the rule
alright so that's good so sorry percent
not a lot yeah how much does the lawyer
take over don't kick it over yet so I'm
not done yet
ah [ __ ] so then then we have 51 percent
tax bracket right where's this in
Seattle Seattle she pays less taxes
still about 51 percent so that goes I
getting 50% of that money
yes yeah and he gets an easy and know
that he's not and there's a certain
amount he gets guaranteed right a
certain amount of youth over certain
years right there's all sorts of bonus
you're still paying you're still paying
essentially fifty one percent fifty
percent in taxes okay
on top of Commission so we're still at
70 grand okay so not sixty we're at 70
million been raised to 10 percent it's
three percent so yeah well no but then
there's probably agents no no you won't
see I'm sorry lawyer lawyer how much is
lawyer take but here's thing most so in
order to be an agent NFL you have to
have your usual lawyer so you do both so
you only pay three percent commission on
that are you sure I'm pretty sure Brian
so he's seen 70 mill still a lot of
money I'll take it well a little less
than 70 pretty cool and then he'll hold
on he'll get you buy a house for 10 360
Oh see how much Wayne's girl Sierra has
I don't think they give a flying [ __ ]
about paying tax who is she our I don't
know if she is know long enough so to
educate you
she's a million gorgeous singer Genoa
hit in a little sector though it's kind
of wow yeah what else she got a lot of
them are just sad so we didn't really
pick more sad ones um anything ahead
well here's one his but how ma did you
see it how much she made for Coachella
HTML eight million which is more than
we're looking at before
Beyonce made like formula she brought
out and sink yeah yeah but with no
Justin Timberlake
so the I think they just came out with a
documentary recently a bunch of guys
from Noah put you guys from early 2000
slash 90s boy bands like Aaron Carter
Backstreet Boys there and members of
NSYNC because they all had the same
manager yes can't all of them he looks
great guy live in Florida yeah how does
it now mmm-hmm apparently they used to
come over to his house and he used to
like show them
oh that guy yeah what's his name creepy
just blew right he was that manager yeah
Lew Wasserman know what it was yeah I
think so and he created Backstreet Boys
NN yeah I mean Lou Osterman Roman roamin
he looked creep all giggle and he liked
his boys there he is there he is oh my
boy watch porn with them yeah apparently
he used to uh have them over at his
house and then put porn on and they
would all just watch your heavens you
guys could you guys get your dicks hard
and you wanna sing he's in prison for 20
years two men well they said they'd oh
my god they said Jesus Christ they said
they'd go on tour and then they'd get
done and like dude where the [ __ ] our
money but you know I all the cost in the
overhead they'd each get like a hundred
bucks the first 100 cities was like 10
grand wait what
their first big Jack after making
millions of dollars for I think it was
NSYNC came out to ten grand they were
taken out to dinner at Lowery's in
Beverly Hills and they were all
expecting it to get like checks for
millions of dollars because they worked
so hard so long and have sold so many
records they came to the dinner opened
up the envelope in it with only ten
grand they're touring like 100 cities
and he gave him ten grand they're like
what the [ __ ] and he's like due to
overhead you know all the water getting
we put in he died right into 2016 good
piece of [ __ ] but Justin Timberlake is
in the documentary I think he's you
don't have time his [ __ ] he's like
what do you want to do and see what you
know what you bigger is than them you he
was always the most talented by far it
was how like Beyonce when you watch
Beyonce in the [ __ ] what was
Destiny's Child like what are we doing
here she was I tell you I was later knew
I was in trouble like this is Michael
avenatti I mean he's looking at 225
years he's rude to you I mean this is a
guy who was like you know the cable King
and doing all this stuff and all
something like dude you you were
cheating a lot of people enjoy that
enjoy the US government no Lou Pearlman
he's dead yeah no shout-out to the
pedophile swindler problem shut up
Perelman 25 years in jail enjoy that
junior getting mad no that's it that's
it
fantastic marry our kids well we did it
Brian another one another one
don't lean on the mic like that all time
your nose it's so weird I like to do it
I don't know man it's such a resting
place for me I'm the only one that uses
this mic well you lean how it like that
yep it's comfy you know yeah feels like
see you wear that it's rare that I see
you wear the same shoes again you've
worn those shoes a couple of times no
warm last week all comfy are they yeah
super comfy I'm into him right now there
you go you got to stand up tonight at
the Laugh Factory
yeah our shows Thursday chemists are
sold out but next week the ones aren't
sold out are in Phoenix stand-up live
Phoenix Friday Saturday after them and
Tampa May 10th through the 11th I'm in
Cleveland Cleveland first time being
there Cleveland May 30th to June first
get your tickets now chief at kake.com
Denver sold out but we're adding a
Thursday show a late show on Thursday so
there are there will be tickets
available for the yes a show but see my
mama needs six digits I got your mom and
I know Jake's coming and J and all my
peeps Miami May 9 10 11 get your ticket
great club your energy I mean no one's
buying the stakes unless I want to be
sexy and bring it down
no one's buying this to you lando
Orlando Disneyland
Orlando improv May 17-18 you've done the
Orlando improv you nope anything to say
about that never been there place is
terrible
oh I have been there just kidding yeah
it's cool yeah good place my late uncle
Linda you could go to Disney World if
you want a little little bit of Drive
teasing wrong from there they could do
it I could write comedy Mickey TPACK a
dot-com for Brian and myself
Phoenix see next week this is a 500 kid
and a fellow agents get 3% we're out